what's going on guys this is rob and uh
moon night episode two god there were a
ton of different easter eggs over the
course of this episode so we're gonna
cover a bunch of them although there may
be a few that we have missed here and
there the first thing i do i want to do
here is i want to talk about an easter
egg that i personally didn't find but a
lot of people are referencing but
they're only referencing a small portion
of it right you gotta reference the
whole thing so uh there's a scene in the
show which by the way spoilers i don't
know anybody who would watch this and
wouldn't expect spoilers there is a
point when mark goes to i guess steve
grant that persona
goes to find his storage unit that
belongs to mark spector and the storage
unit is numbered 43. a lot of people are
saying this is a moon or this is a
reference to moon night vol 1 issue
number 43 which was released in 1992 and
people are saying that's kind of an
easter egg because it's a reference to
the eternals and dade whitman who was
played by ken harrington that kind of a
thing it's a lot bigger than that so
here's the thing moonlight volume 1
issue number 43 when it was released in
1992 was part of a story which has the
same name as a movie that the marvel
cinematic universe recently made and
probably one of the biggest movies the
mcu recently made which is infinity war
so infinity war in 1992 of course was a
follow-up to infinity gauntlet totally
different story but in effect what had
happened is an evil alter ego or i guess
the evil version of adam warlock known
as the magus got his hands on what he
thought was the infinity gauntlet only
to find out that thanos tricked him when
he gave him a fake reality stone but the
thing about this is that there was a
point in that story where
in order to keep the heroes distracted i
guess decent enough reason basically the
magus created a bunch of doppelgangers
of heroes that we know and of course
that basically led to moon knight
teaming up with like us agent and
teaming up with dane whitman and like
the x-men and a bunch of different
characters in order to face off against
those doppelgangers so whether or not
this is an actual reference to the
events or at least to the the eternals
themselves i don't necessarily know uh
maybe but it is a cool little easter egg
to have in there having said that let's
get into the stuff that we found okay so
one mark specter kind of gets an origin
but not really right so the origin
that's really given to us is by the two
detectives that basically arrest him
which we'll talk about them here in a
second because they're characters from
the comics and uh what they really say
here is that essentially mark and his
ilk right when he was part of a of a
mercenary team ended up basically
killing the archaeologist and then
shooting him in the back of the head
right they literally tied him down shot
on the back of the head and that was it
now that's only one part of the story in
the comics the whole context of the
story is that basically uh the architect
and what was his daughter supposed to be
his daughter at the time marlene already
and then in turn mark spector were
basically attacked and left for dead by
raul bushman uh rob bushman of course
being the kind of head guy who was
essentially running the show outside of
the archaeologist
we don't know if rob bushman exists in
the show maybe he does i haven't seen
anything to indicate that he does maybe
i miss his name in the credits or
something like that maybe he will maybe
he won't but the origin story as it's
given to us in in this episode is only
one part of the equation i imagine as
time goes on we'll get the full origin
of mark spectre maybe it doesn't seem
like it's super important to the nature
of mark given everything else that's
going on it seems like what's happening
in the present is way more important
than what happened in the past but there
are a lot of unleft answers in terms of
like what were the terms of the deal
that were struck between like mark
spector and kanchu outside of the fact
that mark spector would be his agent on
earth so indirectly and and directly to
a degree a lot of the questions that we
would have in so far as like how did
mark specter come under the service of
konshu and so on and so forth a lot of
those really seem to have been answered
so we may not get that full origin
that's something to kind of prepare
yourself for because again at this point
it doesn't seem absolutely necessary uh
having said that let's move on to arthur
harrow now this is a huge thing this is
a totally different thing because arthur
harrow does a couple different things
here one he references the idea that
mark specter or steve grant when he's
talking to steve says that like he was
chosen as the avatar of konju because
his mind was broken or at least kind of
asked the question is that the reason
why this is a direct reference to jeff
lemire's moon knight run where in that
story konchu readily admits to to like
moon knight mark spector steve grant
whatever you want to call him that he
did choose him because his mind was
broken and they manipulated now the
other part of this in terms of jeff
lemire's run and the reason why it was
so important is because what you ended
up learning is that the the goal of
conscious here is to quite literally
quote unquote hollow out the uh the
vessel or the the avatar that he has
chosen so that in turn at a future point
in time conscious can basically possess
them and then re-enter into the mortal
world of course moon knight basically
stands in the way of that but it's a
cool little easter egg here right
literally referencing jeff lemire's run
which as i understand it was a massive
influence on this show and you can feel
it if you ever read jeff lemire's moon
night run you can definitely see where
there are huge huge influences here now
the other thing about this that's really
interesting is that arthur says that he
was previously a fist of conscie this is
a totally new development for the show
this did not exist in the comics in the
comics arthur herrera was just an
[ __ ] who was obsessed with pain
that's all he was right like he was like
one of the first or kind of a
significant villain to a degree that
moon knight fought relatively early on
in his his career and that was basically
it there wasn't really anything other
than that to this guy so the marvel
cinematic universe is drastically
changing the role of arthur harrow in
the mcu which kind of seems to be an
ongoing thing while the netflix series
never quite got a chance to finish it
danny rand was basically the most recent
iron fist and you actually ended up
learning that there were other iron
fists that came before him we never got
to see how far reaching that went
because they ended up dropping the the
series after season one which coincided
with the fact that one that first season
was garbage and two because of the fact
that basically the whole deal with
disney and netflix came to an end and
the characters went back so fingers
crossed disney re-does iron fist and
actually makes it good now the next
thing that goes on here
i'm sorry i had to take pot shots i had
to take pot shots here the other thing
that goes on here is we're introduced to
layla layla of course being the wife of
mark spector now this is interesting
here because when i initially saw the
character of layla in episode one when
like her number appeared a zillion times
we for the most part suspected that she
was probably marlene from the comics uh
basically the wife or would eventually
become the wife of mark spector and then
eventually they would divorce uh but we
largely suspected that was the case we
didn't know for sure this episode
solidifies that and thank god because my
biggest fear in the beginning in the
first episode was that was layla miller
and i was like i really hope not because
she sucks she serves no useful purpose
in the comics for those of you guys who
don't know who layla miller is layla
miller was a character that was created
by brian michael bendis when he wrote
house of m and was literally a way for
him to just give himself away out of the
story right like this girl was just a
girl who knows things and like things
aren't the way they're supposed to be
and like she knows how things are
supposed to be like she's a walking
talking plot device that's literally all
she is are you a marvel comics writer
have you written yourself into a hole do
you not know how to get yourself out of
the corner that you've created and this
phenomenal story that you've written
well let me introduce you to leila
miller
the 100 guaranteed way to get out of a
hole like she's she's 100 useless so
thank god she's not here in all reality
layla is by all standards of measurement
marlin just by a different name now how
much of her history will will contribute
to marlene we're not a hundred percent
sure it could be that she really is the
daughter of the archaeologist his name
escapes me uh but like you know it could
be that she's the daughter of that guy
and like mark specter was there and so
on and so forth it could be they have a
more intense history together it seems
like it does right because a lot of our
history as far as layla's concern and a
little bit of an explanation we got is
very similar to marlene in the sense
that like marlene and mark spectre went
on a whole bunch of adventures and did a
whole bunch of different things together
you know after they had fallen in love
and become a power couple and so on and
so forth so i'm curious to see
how far this is going to go now one of
the things i also want to point out is
the portal that arthur hero opens is
actually a portal that leads to a place
called the duat i think it's how you
pronounce it but it's basically the
realm of the dead in the egyptian mythos
and so in effect that's where the
jackals and those things come from which
seems to be that they focus that's
really the realm of like anubis and
that's kind of interesting in that way
but regardless uh that's that's that
little little easter egg reference thing
essentially he's just harnessing the
power of of amit so again i guess maybe
not necessarily an easter egg more so
just kind of like this is what he's
doing in this show uh but another really
cool little easter egg is in the fight
between mr knight who we'll talk about
here in a second uh which i know a lot
of you guys are probably wondering about
him in the fight between mr knight and
the jackal which nobody but mr knight
can see uh there's a point where he gets
knocked into one of those uh red british
buses which i've always wanted to ride
and never had a chance to they just look
cool and uh and there's a an ad there
for the global repatriation council now
for those of you guys who watch falcon
and the winter soldier you know that grc
is the organization that was introduced
which is basically reintegrating people
back into society after they were
blinked out of existence during the
thanos snap and then brought back by the
incredible hulk they also seem kind of
shady but the thing about this is like
it's a reference to them which is cool
it's cool to see the small little
tidbits of things that have been
established in the mcu being referenced
in other shows now i don't necessarily
consider this next one to be an absolute
easter egg really more of just personal
interpretation but the rooftop scene
where the jackal is chasing uh the
actual mark specter or the actual moon
night the proper moon night after mark
spectre takes over in terms of like
being the the prime personality that is
a reference to the old werewolf by night
appearance right when moon knight first
appeared and fought werewolf by night
there's a couple reasons why i say that
one because that rooftop scene is kind
of iconic and two because the jackal
literally looks like a werewolf it
really really does uh it's probably not
jack russell who was the identity of
werewolf by night like we saw it crawl
out of the ground so unless jack russell
had just been hanging out in the realm
of the dead under the service of amit
it's not him
but it is a cool little reference and i
am excited to see uh where that where
that leads us to in the future of the
the moon night episodes but the next two
thing the two detectives who arrested
mark spector those are in reference to
bobby and billy from jeff lemire's moon
night run instead of them being
detectives in the moon night run they're
actually orderly's working at the mental
institution that are designed to
basically keep mark spector imprisoned
there so again it's not a huge shift not
a great big huge change but still a cool
small little thing nonetheless right
just a cool little reference to the
influence that jeff lemire's run had
on the moon night show and that leads us
to probably the biggest thing in the
moon night episode which is mr knight
now here's the thing yes mr knight does
look every bit as awesome in the comics
as he does in the show and yes when mr
knight first appeared when he was first
created by warren ellis in his moon
night run
everybody was dressed as him at
comic-cons everywhere and that's
probably going to be an even higher
number now
because mr knight just looks cool so
what's the deal with mr knight and how
does he differentiate from moon knight
the best way to think about this is the
relationship between moon knight and mr
knight almost mirrors the relationship
between mark spector and steve grant
jake lockley of course we've talked
about before he's the cab driver persona
the guy that keeps his ear to the ground
doesn't really want to be noticed but
where mark spector is like the mercenary
the hardcore moon knight kills people
whenever he has to kind of thing steve
grant is more of like the wealthy kind
of up there to do keeping his eye and
keeping his ear on like white-collar
crime different things like that and
using the money that that comes from uh
from grant industries to basically fund
the the moon knight
events right allow them to basically
operate um the relationship between moon
knight and mr knight is very similar to
that where moon knight is like the
vigilante running around in the middle
of the night beating people up usually
killing them mr knight is more of like
the the publicly acceptable front face
of that right he's a wholly different
personality it's not moon knight dressed
up in a different outfit he's a wholly
different guy a whole different
personality but he's very sherlock
holmes-esque in terms of how he works
he's got a relationship with police
officers different things along those
lines so he's kind of the he's like
batman but like more socially acceptable
and cooler to be honest
that's kind of his thing right now in
marvel comics in fact with jed mccade's
run on moon night it is focusing on mr
night with basically like the midnight
mission that kind of a thing uh but make
no mistake right mr knight still like
protects the vulnerable and the weak and
that kind of a thing he's just not
necessarily as extreme and violent as
moon knight is that's why if you go when
you read uh read the moon knight comics
right now by jed mckay it's mr knight
who like listens to people's problems
when they come to him they say this is a
thing that i'm struggling with but like
when he leaps into action and starts
[ __ ] people up he's moon knight so
that's basically what's going on you
know with regards to those two
personalities i am excited to see it the
biggest thing here though is that it
doesn't really look like mr knight in
the moon night show
matches mr knight from the comics it
really looks more like mr knight is just
the steve grant version of moon knight
is all it is right the polite moon
knight
he's gonna beat the crap out of you but
in the nicest way you know like you look
great with blood on your shirt
right that gash across your forehead
really brings out the color of your eyes
you know that's the kind of thing that
you would expect you know from from mr
knight again more of a a very kind of
mild-mannered moon knight to a degree so
i don't really know if we're going to
see him again i really hope we do and i
really hope they they kind of build him
up again there's not a ton of episodes
here if we had like 12 or 13 episodes to
work with sure but as far as i'm aware i
think we're limited to six which is kind
of the status quo with disney plus
marvel shows now uh so i am curious to
see where they go with it but
nonetheless guys let's talk about the
ending right the ending of the show with
basically mark steve whoever waking up
in what looks like a really cool hotel
uh in egypt right we obviously know this
is going to lead more into like the
egyptian mythos what i'm really hoping
this does is it delves more into like
the various gods that exist out there in
the events of like the moon knight
mythos because one of the things that i
hope you guys are noticing here is that
with thor love and thunder coming out
that one focusing on god the gore the
god butcher and the idea that gore is
basically a being who travels around the
universe at least in the comics anyway
and kills all the different gods that we
can that he can find right now we're in
the age of gods when it comes to the
entirety of the uh of the the marvel
cinematic universe the only exception to
that potentially being doctor strange
too but even then we're not entirely
sure although rumors abound especially
given the current uh dreams trailer that
nightmare is the person who's involved
uh then it would make sense so we're
dealing more with like gods and cosmic
beings than we are anything else so moon
knight fits in perfectly with that and
so now would be a great opportunity to
introduce like a lot of these other gods
that exist out there and while we
wouldn't necessarily get into like the
hindu god vishnu or anything like that
the fact that bast originally started as
an egyptian god and then eventually
became the wakandan god and really the
wakandan patron saint of the black
panther clan uh it would be cool to have
a reference there right to have
something where they're just like yeah
and then bass over there who hangs out
with the wakandans she started here bro
she used to sit at the cool kids table
and now she's at like the super cool
kids table so she's too good for us now
apparently right brings her own lunch
and everything i mean it'd be cool if
they if they did that right which would
be a really interesting concept i don't
know if they will i would really like it
if they did because i feel like it would
just really tie together the mcu in a
way that kind of hasn't been done right
because the only real things that we've
seen that have kind of unified the
marvel cinematic universe have been like
the avengers teaming up and like that's
kind of it right and like blade's voice
in the background at the end of the
eternals in the post-credits scene like
that's really all we have right but
basically saying that like bass was once
an egyptian god and is like the sister
and or brother because gods don't really
have a have a gender but like the sister
and or brother of like honshu it'd be a
great way to kind of unify things and to
really bring back this idea that like it
is all a shared universe right because i
don't know about you guys but like the
shows are cool the movies are cool
but it kind of feels like things are
just sort of moving off into their own
direction and everything kind of feels
isolated to a degree i don't know if i'm
the only one feeling that let me know if
you guys are but i'm kind of feeling
that here so i really feel like
referencing bass is like the panther god
that now resides or looks over the
wakandans but originally started out as
an egyptian god would be a great way to
kind of bring that unification back into
play again so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end uh
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later peace